bonjour ou la table merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
arte france il y a eu des nouvelles
manifestations et hier au liban les
étudiants qui ont manifesté contre la
hausse de leurs tarifs de scolarité ça
fait partie d'une crise plus globale
expliquez nous bonjour effectivement les
étudiants sont très énervés ainsi que
leurs parents mais j'aimerais bien
souligner ici que le secteur privé en
l'occurrence les universités privées au
liban sont aussi aux six victimes que le
reste du peuple de la politique la
politique financière et économique qui a
été suivi les dernières quinze années je
comprends leur colère
je la comprends très bien mais c'est pas
contre les universités privées qu'il a
qui doivent s'en prendre ses modèles
alors qu emmanuel macron très engagé
pour le liban a réitéré ses exigences de
réformes envers le pays c'était la
semaine dernière qu on en est
aujourd'hui de ces réformes c'est le
statu quo toujours depuis la visite de
monsieur mc ren le lendemain de
l'explosion presque atone ict à beyrouth
il a beau essayer avec les dirigeants
libanais les dirigeants des cartels
parce que ça même pas des politiciens il
on a su dès le début qu'ils ne valaient
rien faire qui n'allait pas faire les
réformes parce que toute réforme dire la
fin de leur parti politique de leur
pouvoir
c'est des mafieux qui ont conquis en qui
ont détruit le liban pendant les trente
dernières années et qui sont au pouvoir
depuis depuis que je connais que je suis
là c'est des gens qui ont tout volé ils
ont relais les caisses du gouvernement
et maintenant ils sont en train de voler
l'argent
les épargnes du paf dans les dents les
banques
ils ont vraiment tout prix c'est il
n'est pas question que le liban puisse
retrouver sa santé et dans la présence
de cette classe politique comment
comment on finir justement alors avec
cette impasse politique selon vous on
sait qu emmanuel lacroix a dû annuler
son voyage à cause de de sa maladie au
co vide qu'on vous attendez encore que
la france vienne au secours de votre
pays j'espère bien que la france mais la
france ne suffira pas et je pense que ça
doit être une décision globale des
nations unies de nous prendre prendre en
charge parce que le libanais aujourd'hui
il est l'otage
il est l'otage d'un côté et de l'agenda
de l'iran pour la région et d'un autre
côté une classe mafieuses qui est qui
qui nous nous sommes les otages de la
classe politique et du chocolat
si le monde ne veut plus souffrir d'une
autre guerre civile dans cette partie du
monde
et bien je crois que les nations unies
doivent prendre une décision ferme
en ce qui nous concerne et ils sont les
bienvenus
on parle de la crise économique
politique bien évidemment est ce que
vous craignez des crues et dévoila est
ce que vous craignez justement d'aider
conséquences sécuritaires dans le pays
on a vu aussi que l'actualité de ces
derniers jours a été marquée par cet
incendie dans un camp de réfugiés ou des
libanais
et des syriens la règlement de comptes
entre libanais et syriens elle est là
cette crise sécuritaire aujourd'hui est
évidemment et moi je ne pense pas que
c'était une incidence problème entre
familles syriennes et familles
libanaises
nous avons tous les droits de penser que
c'était effectivement une tierce partie
qui voudrait à un moment donné utilisez
les cantiliens comme à l'époque 175 vont
utiliser les palestiniens pour créer
pour commencer à une guerre civile
et je crois que cette classe politique
elle est tellement corrompus tellement
sans foi ni loi
s'ils sont en danger imminent il
pourrait évidemment utiliser les syriens
pour mettre la pression sur le peuple
libanais internationale aussi un oeil
est aussi une crise sanitaire
on le sait le liban aura peut-être le
vaccin en février pas avant qu'en est il
de cette situation est ce qu'elle est
alarmante
elle est catastrophique madame moi je
passe mon test qu'aux vie de chat quatre
jours parce que je n'avais pas mettre à
risque
ma famille et les gens que j'aime et
évidemment hier la dame qui me prend le
peste m a assuré que sur chaque type est
si positif alors ça veut dire voulant
dire que soit 100 % de la population est
atteinte il ya une réelle le pression
sur le système hospitalier aujourd'hui
est énorme énorme et surtout tout aussi
à cause à cause de la nef libanaise
vis-à-vis du dollar à cause de la crise
économique et financière
les hôpitaux sont surtout les hôpitaux
privés sont vraiment dans une situation
aussi alarmante mercerat palace une
liste en tout le monde
merci beaucoup la tâche de nous avoir
livré ce témoignage ce matin en direct
sur arte france